Dear Jesus, may I enter into the eternal divine order of God to place my absolute
nothingness in the heart of the most holy trinity, to give to my God the joy of fulfilling the
purpose of my existence by doing all the acts of my life through the immaculate heart of my mother
Mary and in the divine will of God. And in this same manner may I live, pray, act, eat, walk,
sleep, and do everything. May my soul be devoid of any other longings, wants or desires,
and may you my beloved divine will do with me whatever you want or desire. All I ask is that
you bind me to your most holy will so intimately that I may never swear from carrying out what I
know to be your good pleasure, and that I remain so docile to the movements of your divine will
that you never perceive even a breath of resistance in my soul to your requests of me. Come divine
will with all the angels and saints, especially my sweet mother Mary, to touch my forehead,
to imprint on it the Holy Spirit, and infuse in me true light, so that I may understand the truths
and the good that are in these writings and prayers. Amen. So we start tonight with July the 14th,
1926. And here the Lord is talking about in the first paragraph, putting our I love you on
everything if possible. Louisa said, I continue my usual fusions in the divine will. I think
that's a wonderful expression there, my usual fusions, because Jesus tells us to fuse ourselves
in him before we do anything in the divine will to make sure that we really are in the divine will.
And here she is absolutely inseparable with the divine will at this particular stage,
and she still does it, which is very important message for us. Many times my sweet Jesus accompanies
me in the repetition of these acts. There is the Lord praying with us, the very same acts that we're
actually doing ourselves. He stays there to see whether anything escapes me of all that he has
done, both in creation and in redemption. And all goodness, he makes it present to me that I may
place even just one little, I love you, one, I thank you, one adoration, telling me that it is
necessary to recognize to what extent he has extended the boundaries of the kingdom of his
volition for love of the creature, that she may go around in the kingdom and enjoy it,
and through her love take possession of it, and that she may become more stable herself,
I love that statement. So it's very clear here that we have to be touring the kingdom to put our
signature, that's where I like to put it, on absolutely everything. And whatever you put your
signature to, the Lord allows you to take possession of that. Not when you do it once, it's when you
do it many, many, many, many times, and the kingdom of the divine will expand more and more
inside of you. And so he wants us to continue to go around the kingdom to enjoy it and take possession
of it. What this reminds me of is somebody owning a largest state, and they take a tour of the
estate and they'll go into one part of it and then into another and be amazed that they have
forgotten that this part actually exists. And so traveling around the estate is actually quite
important. And then we become more stable in the way we pray and deal with the kingdom of the divine
will. And then seeing her always in the kingdom of the divine will or in your estate, everyone both
in heaven and on earth will recognize that the kingdom of the divine will has delivered its
heiress who loves it and is happy to possess it. So when we travel around the kingdom of the
divine will and place our signature on absolutely everything, what he's saying is that heaven and
earth begins to acknowledge that there is somebody there who wants to take possession of the kingdom.
Of course, it refers to Louisa more than us because she was the heiress to whom it was all given.
In the next paragraph, Jesus shows himself with rays coming out from his heart and his eyes and
his mouth and everywhere. And at the end of each one of these rays, there is a theat. And for those
of you who have done the book of Revelation with me in this paragraph, Jesus is going to talk about
the seal of the divine fiat and the mark of the divine fiat. And that is much, much more important
than the fear people have of the mark and the seal of the beast in Revelation 13. So this is
the second paragraph. While I was feeling sunken in the divine volition, look at the word sunken.
This is not superficial stuff. This is us getting right in there into the heart of God,
into the heart of the most holy Trinity and entering in, taking possession of the kingdom and letting
him expand the kingdom in us as much as possible. So my beloved Jesus made himself seen with his
heart open and at each heartbeat of his, a ray of light came out at the tip of which one could see
a fiat impressed. So that must have been absolutely amazing with each heartbeat.
And since the beating of the heart is continuous, as one ray would come out, another would follow,
and then another one, and it just never stopped coming out. These rays invaded both heaven and
earth, but all of them carried the fiat impressed on them. We have to remember this for where he's
going now. So every one of the rays has the fiat actually impressed on them. But as he looked,
rays also came out from his eyes. And as he spoke, and as he moved his hands and his feet,
rays came out from them, and they all carried the supreme fiat as glory and triumph. It must
have been an absolutely amazing thing to see. It was an enchantment to see Jesus like this,
beautiful and all transfused in these rays of light, which came out of his adorable person.
But what gave him sumptuousness is what she calls it, majesty, magnificent, glory, beauty,
was the fiat. So first of all, she sees the person of Jesus, and she's seeing him in glory,
but she's seeing a fiat coming out from every part of his being. So the Saint Paul said,
Jesus is the yes to God, and he's the yes to God for us all. I haven't got that reference for
you. It's only come to me just at this moment. So the fiat is just impressed on absolutely
everything to do with him. It's light. He plipsed me, Louisa said, and I would have stayed there for
centuries before Jesus without saying anything to him. So she just stayed in adoration. If he
himself had not broken the silence telling me, my daughter, the perfect glory and the complete
honor were given to my will by my humanity. Now there you've got the operative sentence that
explains everything that went before it. Jesus is the yes to God on behalf of humanity. And so
every part of his sacred humanity actually just oozed the yes to God. Yes, yes, yes. And of course
it was all in reparation for the rest of the human race that was saying no to God. And it was his
redeeming every thought, every word, every movement of the eyelashes, every seeing, every hearing,
every speaking, everything, every heartbeat. He was redeeming everything. So Jesus continued,
the perfect glory and complete honor were given to my will through my humanity. It was precisely in
my interior in the center of this heart that I formed the kingdom of the supreme will. Now the
whole living of the divine will is completely interior. Nobody outside of you can see it. And
it's what's going on in the interior of our being that enables the kingdom of the divine will to
spread upon the earth. And since man had lost the divine will, there was no hope that he might be
able to reacquire it. So my humanity reacquired it through intimate and unheard of pain. Now the
whole thing is love and pain, love and suffering. While we are on the earth, there's no way out of
the suffering, love and suffering is the mystery that goes together. And the more we learn how to
love, the more we will say yes to the cross, say yes to the suffering. Now in the chastisments that
are coming to the earth in the near future, we're going to all have to know how to say yes to the
suffering for the sake of the redemption of humanity in the divine will. So what he's saying here is
absolutely vital to us. So Jesus said that his humanity was the one that reacquired the divine
will through intimate and unheard of pain, giving the divine will all the honor that was due to it.
And all the glory that the creature took away from it. So you see the reparation in the substitution
there. So as to give the divine will back to humanity. So the kingdom of my will was formed
inside of my humanity and the kingdom of the divine will is formed inside of yours and mine as well.
Luke 1721, the kingdom of God is within you. And therefore everything that was formed in my
humanity and came out of it, carried the mark the fiat. Now this is precisely what we have to carry
the mark of the fiat through our lives and carry it to heaven as the true children of the Lord.
Each one of my thoughts, gazes, breaths, heartbeats, each drop of my blood, everything carried the
seal of the fiat. Now notice the mark and the seal are the same thing, carried the seal of the
fiat of my supreme kingdom. This gave me so much glory and embellished me so much that heaven and
earth remained below as though obscured by me because my divine will is superior to everything
and puts everything under its footstool. I read that a bit quick for you. There's a lot of scriptures
on everything being the footstool. I want to give you Matthew chapter 5 verse 35. The earth itself
is his footstool. I want to give you Sam 99 verse 5 that we worship at the footstool of the Lord
and Sam 132 verse 7 for the same thing. There are more but that just at least expresses it.
So everything inside of the humanity of Jesus, everything exterior and interior to his humanity
had the seal and the mark of the fiat. That is exactly what he's asking for us as well.
Now in the next paragraph Jesus compares the divine will to a pregnant woman. It's very,
very unusual for that image to be used. Now in the round of the centuries, because he had to wait
2000 years, 20 centuries, I looked for one to whom to entrust this kingdom. And I've been like a
pregnant mother who agonizes, who suffers because she wants to deliver the baby but cannot do it.
The poor mother really suffers for she cannot enjoy the fruit of her womb. More so since,
and this is the very interesting thing, so he's talking about the very end of pregnancy. Since the
existence of this birth of which is mature, if it doesn't come out is always in danger, as all
women know, it's very interesting. So Jesus was saying that the divine will was in agony to give
birth to the kingdom of God, kingdom of the divine will. So more than a pregnant mother have I been
for many centuries. That means absolute agony and how much I suffered, how I have agonized in seeing
the interests of my glory in danger, both of creation and redemption. And that's because people
were not living in the divine will. More so since I kept this kingdom of the divine will as though
in secret and hidden in my heart, as he said, he established it in his heart without even the
outlet of manifesting it. And this made me agonize even more because not seeing in the creatures,
the true dispositions. Now you know why he had to wait so long. He had to wait until he found one
with the true dispositions. So not seeing in them the true dispositions that I might give birth
from myself. And since they had not taken all the goods contained in the kingdom of redemption,
I couldn't venture to give them the kingdom of my will which contains greater goods.
So notice that if we don't take the goods of redemption, we cannot enter the kingdom of the
divine will. Now there are so many people on the earth today in that position that the church
really urgently needs to evangelize them because they must take the goods of the kingdom of redemption
before they can enter the kingdom of the divine will because that is the crown of sanctity.
So more so, he said, since the goods of redemption will serve as provision,
as antidote. So that's your healing aspect. So that on entering the kingdom of my will,
they may not repeat a second fall like that of Adam. You see why the Lord had to wait. He's made
it very clear. He couldn't risk another Adamic crisis. He couldn't do it because how many centuries
would he have to wait again? But also since redemption has already happened, redemption
couldn't be repeated. So he had to be extremely careful. I think this is a very important passage
for any of you who are trying to explain this to other people as to why the Lord waited 20 centuries
before he actually revealed the kingdom of the divine will. So he couldn't risk a second fall
like that of Adam. So if not all of these goods had been taken on the country, they've been
tampered with and trampled upon. How could this birth of my kingdom come out from within my
humanity? Now, how could we tamper and trample on the goods of the kingdom of the redemption?
Well, first of all, I'll just give you the first example that comes to my head. And that is that
we've had scripture scholars and we have theologians who have made all kinds of comments and all the
rest of it. And some of them have really, really destroyed the message and have had to be corrected
by the church and so on. That's just one example. There are others. Also, the misuse of the sacred
liturgy would mean trampling upon the graces and the gifts of redemption. So we go on with his waiting
for centuries. Therefore, I contented myself with agonizing suffering and waiting more than a mother.
So as not to expose this dear birth from myself, my kingdom to any danger. And so, while agonizing
for I wanted to deliver the divine will and to give it to the creature as a gift,
there you have this inexplicable love of God. He has just told us he couldn't do it for centuries
because we had to have the right dispositions and we hadn't even taken advantage of redemption
as we showed. And he still has it in his heart to give this extraordinary, this most incredible gift
to us, to creatures who absolutely don't deserve it and are so ungrateful. So I wanted to deliver
the divine will as a gift and to secure the interest of both creation and redemption,
which were all in danger when people wouldn't come into the divine will. In fact, until man
returns into the kingdom of the supreme will our interests and his will always be in danger.
Now people don't seem to consider the fact that when they throw God out their own eternal interests
are thrown out as well. They don't seem to consider that. So our interests and his will always be in
danger because outside of our will, man is always a disorder. He's always a disorder in our creative
work. He's the clashing note that takes the perfect harmony away from the sanctity of our works.
I looked at the round of centuries, Jesus said, waiting for my little newborn of the kingdom of
my will. So he was waiting for Louisa and placing around her all the goods of redemption, that means
the fullness of redemption. And we know he gave her the fullness of redemption because he also took
away the effects of original sin from her for the safety of the kingdom of my will. So she had to
have all the goods of redemption in order to be able to go on. And that's why it's so important
for us to explain to people who are joining us in early classes that they have to be people who are
already living a spiritual life, already committed to the Lord, already using all the means of redemption.
Otherwise they can't come into the kingdom of the divine will because they're not ready.
So all the goods of redemption was given to her. And more than the suffering mother who has
agonized for so long, I entrust to you, Louisa, he's saying, this part from myself. And I entrust
to you the destiny of the kingdom of the divine will. Now I find that more than astonishing. We only
have God speaking. And speaking to a tiny little creature who when he started out revealing this
stuff to her, she didn't have a clue as to where all of this was going. And when she began to realize
where it was going, she got really, really scared. How could this be, you know? And here you have
the almighty ever living, everlasting, omnipotent God, telling this tiny little creature that he
entrusts the kingdom of the divine will and its destiny to her. As far as I'm concerned while we're
looking at is the humility of God, and the humility of God to me is devastating. It's incredible.
We don't associate people in high places with humility. And to see the humility of God is just
amazing. And so he said, I entrust to you, Louisa, this birth from myself and the destiny
of this, my kingdom. And it is not only my humanity that wants to deliver this birth that
costs me so much, but the whole of creation is pregnant with my will. There's Romans 819 again.
The whole of creation waiting for the children of the divine will to show themselves. And the
whole of creation agonizes because it wants to deliver the kingdom of the divine will to creatures
and to establish once again the kingdom of their God in the midst of creatures. Because
when you go back to Genesis chapter three, it was only the human beings that moved out of the will
of God, the animals didn't and the plants didn't. And so a gulf came between creation and humanity.
And you know from Louisa's writings, but you know it very clearly from the book of Revelation that
it is creation that punishes man when things get really bad. Therefore creation is like a veil
that hides my will. And therefore you know if creation says we're going to really disturb you,
then the divine will is behind that. So creation is like a veil that hides my will which is like
a birth within it. And creatures only look at the outer part, the veil, and they reject the divine
will that is inside of it. That's very, very interesting only looking at the externals and not
looking at the reality that is within. That's the mistake human beings make. The kingdom of my will
is also the sun. And while they take the effects of the sun which like a veil conceals my will and
goods, they reject the will which is behind it. So there's a warning here as well not to take the
revelation of the divine will as a devotion. This is a commitment. He's telling us we've got to
break these veils. We've got to see what is in creation. We've got to see what is in the sun and
the moon and the stars. We've got to see what is in humanity. And therefore I love you in all of
creation and in redemption and in sanctification will make much more sense. We will actually know
we're rewearing the divine will in all of these things. But he continues to say human beings take
the externals and they won't go for the internal reality. So they take the natural goods presented
in the sun and they reject the goods of the soul. So there's the choosing of the temporal
over the eternal. So they reject the kingdom of my will that reigns in the sun and wants to give
itself to them. Oh how my will agonizes in the sun wanting to give birth from the height of its
sphere in order to reign in the midst of creatures. And then of course he goes on the kingdom of my
will is in the sky in the sea and so on. The kingdom of my will is in the sky looking at the creatures
with the eyes of light which are the stars to see if they want to receive it so that it may reign
in their midst. So the stars are beaming down on us and we look at the stars and we name them and
we count them and we don't see the divine will there at all. The kingdom of my will is in the sea
it makes itself heard with its roaring waves and its waters hide the divine will like a veil.
But man makes use of the sea takes the fish doesn't bother about my will and causes the divine will
to agonize like a birth constrained in the womb of the waters. So all the elements are pregnant with
my will the wind the fire the flower the whole earth they are all veils that conceal the divine
will. Can't you see that we would become an adoring community if we saw God in absolutely
everything. So let's ask a question. Who will give this outlet and relief to my humanity? Who will
break these veils of so many created things that conceal the divine will. The answer is one who will
recognize in all things the bearers of my will and paying the honors due to it will let the divine
will reign in her soul giving it dominion and subject in other words someone who lives in the
divine will. Now notice you have to recognize that all things are the bearers of the divine will
I think it's absolutely fantastic I have a problem then you see going going out to pull up the weeds
if they are bearers of the divine will that's just a personal problem where therefore my daughter
Jesus said be attentive give this contentment to your Jesus who has agonized so much until now
to release this birth of the supreme kingdom and together with me the whole of creation as one single
act will break the veils and will deposit in you the birth of the kingdom isn't that fantastic
and of course by volume 19 this is already long since happened to Louisa so let's go to
July the 18th 1926 so we continue the same message because it's why the Lord didn't manifest the
kingdom of his will when he came on earth so Louisa said my poor mind was thinking about what is
written above and my sweet Jesus continued on the same topic telling me my daughter see then the
necessity for me not to give the kingdom of my will and not to make it known when I came on the
earth the dispositions weren't there the people weren't ready I wanted to test the creature once
again this is very very interesting when you study the Old Testament particularly this is brought out
time out of number and if you're doing the book of numbers with me you're going to see it every
time we have a class that when God gives a gift it is a test as well what will you do with his gift
how will you respond to the gift if you remember the the talents and the one with one talent
didn't use the gift at all threw it back at the the master and had to take the consequences
so the giving of a gift is a test so the giving of the gift of the divine will since it's the
greatest of the gifts that he's giving is a huge test for us okay I wanted to test the creature
once again I wanted to give her things this is when he came in the incarnation I wanted to give her
things inferior to those which I gave her in creation why were the inferior because when human
beings were created they were created perfect and they were created in the divine will but when
Jesus came in the incarnation he had to come and heal and restore and patch up and re evangelize
and so on and so forth so I had to give remedies and goods to heal her so that's the human race
absolutely broken in fact when I created man he was not ill he was healthy and holy and therefore
he could very well live in the kingdom of my will can I stop there for a second and get you to ask
the question inside in your own head why is it accepted that most of the nation is sick
and that we have to build more and more and more and more hospitals don't you think that the
message is that the human race is ill because of the human will when Jesus said when man was created
he was created whole and wholesome and had the divine will raining in him and therefore there was
no sickness no sickness and no death and now we have sickness and death all around us so as he
withdrew from the supreme volition he did feel fall ill and it's not just a physical illness it's
spiritual illness which produces the physical effects and I came upon the earth as the celestial
doctor to see whether he would accept the remedies and the medicines for his illness and after this
test then I would give him the surprise of manifesting the kingdom of my will now after this test is
just simply two thousand years later you have to remember Sam 90 verse 5 with the lord a thousand
years is like a single day and so with the gift of redemption given the human race is then tested
to see what will you do with this gift will you actually take the benefits of this gift will you
grow will you become whole and wholesome will you come back into union with god and if the answer
to all these things is yes then the lord will come back he came back three days later because we're
living on the morning of the third day since the resurrection that is the beginning of the third
millennium and as far as the lord is concerned these are just days they're only a short time so
after this test then I would give him the surprise of manifesting the kingdom of my will
which I kept in my humanity and that's what we've seen now in the first message tonight
we've seen the fiat absolutely everywhere in Jesus's humanity and those who think that our highest
goodness and infinite wisdom would have left man with only the goods of redemption without raising
him again to his original state in which he was created they deceived themselves god is immutable
whatever he has decided that's it whatever he says is good that's it or as we say about the
Ten Commandments they're carved in stone in that case our creation would have remained without
its purpose and therefore without its full effect and that cannot be in the works of god most we might
let centuries pass two hundred of them giving one surprise and then another an entrusting one little
good to the creature and then a greater one in other words he said they had to grow sit by sip
they could only take one little bit and then another little bit now if you have nursed
a sick person into health you know that they can take very little food initially and
just very slowly they will be able to take more and more until they come back to natural food
if you go to Isaiah 29 verse 14 and the first part of it Isaiah wrote that text at a time when
Israel had become really ill spiritually and Isaiah said the Lord will have to surprise you
with one incredible thing after another to try and catch your attention so the blessed trinity
will act like a father who wants to give his property to his children but these children have
wasted much of the goods of the father so there's the prodigal son Luke 15 and the prodigal son of
course is the human race in spite of this he the father is determined to give his property to his
children so he thinks of another way he no longer gives large amounts to his children but a little
bit at a time here's your feeding them sip by sip because she's a Italian lira by lira so that's
euro by euro or dollar by dollar or whatever your currency is and if he sees if they preserve that
little he keeps increasing it in small amounts the image he's giving to you here is of a father
with a child who cannot be trusted with something big and so the father trains the child to take
a small amount of money and to deal with that properly and then he'll increase it a little bit
and then increase it a little bit that's exactly what he does with us in the divine will can i give
you more of this kingdom of the divine will can i expand this inside of you will you deal with it
properly will you make the most of it will you take possession of it will you truly be a child of
the divine will so he gives it to us in small amounts it's very interesting so through this
the children come to recognize the love of the father and to appreciate the goods that he entrusts
to them slowly slowly it hits them very few people actually get divine will overnight very few
it grows on us bit by bit and eventually we can have a eureka moment when you actually wake up to
the realization that i'm living heaven on earth i'm living in the blessed trinity i have an
extraordinary privilege in this prayer and therefore i have an extraordinary responsibility
to everybody else who doesn't have this privilege and so you wake up to your responsibility
to save as many souls as possible in the divine will so they begin to appreciate and so the lord
can increase the goods more and more so this serves to strengthen them i love the very simple
images he uses to tell us something very profound as we take divine will sip by sip and grow and
expand our souls are strengthened and therefore it's able to take more and therefore the lord can
give more so if you're talking about children the child becomes stronger and stronger and so the
father can give more so once he has trained them now notice that this journey in the divine will
is a genuine training i normally use the word purification on it as well and if i give you Hebrews
chapter 12 verses 5 to 7 you will understand why the training and the purification are kind of
synonymous because that's what the letter to the Hebrews chapter 12 says that if the lord doesn't
correct you and put you back in the right way and sort of if you've slipped in any way if he doesn't
put you back you're not going to go anywhere this is training that he actually gives to us
but it means that the lord is very personally involved with each one of us in this personal
training i think that's fascinating so the father confirms his decision and gives his property so
that's giving the gift of the divine will so in the next paragraph he goes back to adam again
and that the gift was given to adam and that this was a test so we have to be alerted to the fact
that the gift is given to us as well and we are also tested in the same way as adam was tested and
that is with obedience now this is how the paternal goodness is acting in creation i placed man in
the opulence of goods everything was given to him in the garden of eden there was no restriction
at all but only because i wanted to test him in something that didn't cost him very much
with an activist will contrary to mine he wasted all his goods now there's something terribly
important here you know the story of the fall of adam that's not what i'm going to be talking about
it is that jesus is saying here that god tests each one of us with something that doesn't actually
cost us a lot in other words he's not looking for something massive from you just something
small and very often it is in the small things we're actually saying no
and if we say no in the small things we will never get the greater things
so that is actually a very important point that he's making there and with an act of his will
he lost everything now an act of his will means that he actually made a decision i'm always fascinated
when i see little two-year-olds saying no they're learning for the first time that they have
something inside of them that gives them the ability to say yes or no and they love the word
no i say my goodness we start early we start very early and so with an act of the will
on something that may not be a major issue we can lose everything i think that needs to be looked
at but my love didn't stop more than a father i began to give him a little at a time and before
that to heal him so many times one uses more attention with the little than when he possesses
great things very interesting god really knows us in fact if one possesses great properties and
they're wasted there's always something there that you can take but if the little is wasted he remains
on an empty stomach okay so there's your talents and the man lost everything because he wouldn't
use the one talent however the decision of giving the kingdom of my will to man i have not changed
because god is immutable man changes but god does not change now things are easier jesus said because
the goods of redemption have already made their way in other words has taken two thousand years
for the members of the church to really benefit and they've made known many surprises of my love
for them how i loved them that's john 15 9 not by the phy at alone but by giving him my very life
the lord has given us himself in the eucharist we have him as the word the written word and the
word incarnate as well so by giving him my very life though my phy at costs me more than my very
humanity because the phy at is divine immense eternal while my humanity is limited and it is small
by comparison it has its beginning in time so regardless of how much he suffered in his humanity
what they divine will suffered is divine immense and eternal it was divine pain
and he tells us that the phy at costs more than anything else however not knowing in depth what
the phy at means not knowing its value not knowing its power and not knowing what it can do
the human mind lets itself be conquered more by all that i did and suffered that's the ad extra
looking simply on the outside like in the stations of the cross we just simply look on the outside
so the human mind lets itself be conquered more by what i did and what i suffered in coming to
redeem them not knowing that under the pains and my death was my phy at hidden and it gave life to
all my pains so we have the privilege of having the hours of the passion in which Jesus actually
reveals the hidden phy at and the hidden passion to us so we have a greater privilege than other
people now he said had i wanted to manifest the kingdom of my will either when i came upon the
earth or before the goods of redemption would be recognized and for the most part possessed
notice for the most part we don't take it all by creatures my greatest saints would have been
frightened this is very interesting now he's talking about my greatest saints we're not talking
even just about little ones they would have been frightened all of them would have said
Adam innocent and holy was unable to live or to persevere in the kingdom of endless light
and of divine sanctity so how could we do it so if that was all that we had to look at
they wouldn't have been able to reach out for it and you yourself he said how many times have you
become frightened and trembling before the immense goods of the sanctity fully divine of the kingdom
of my supreme phy at you wanted to draw back as well he said to louise you were saying to me
Jesus think of some other creature i'm not capable of this you were not so much frightened by the
suffering rather many times you prayed me you incited me to let you suffer that she was very very
brave with regard to suffering for the sake of souls so therefore my more than paternal goodness
acted with you as with the second mother that is volumes one and two where he asked louise it to
be a second mother to him on the earth therefore my more than paternal goodness acted with you as
with the second mother of mine from her i hid my conception in her womb first i prepared her i
formed her so as not to frighten her and then at the appropriate time in the very act in which i
was conceived then i made known to her through the angel and even though at first she trembled
and was troubled immediately she became serene again because she was used to living with her god
now i read that quickly because all of that is very familiar to you but what jesus is saying is
that he's behaved like that with louise as well exactly the same so she was used to living with
her god and she was used to living in the midst of his light and before his sanctity and that's
what i've done with you for many years and years this is volumes one to ten i hid from you that i
wanted to form the supreme kingdom of the divine will in you but i prepared you i formed you
i enclosed myself in you in the depth of your soul in order to form the kingdom of the divine
will and when everything was done i manifested the secret to you i spoke to you about your special
mission i asked you in a formal way whether you wanted to accept the divine will and even though
you trembled and feared i reassured you saying to you why do you trouble yourself have you perhaps
not lived with me until now in the kingdom of my will so by the time jesus actually began to reveal
the kingdom to louise you're talking now volumes 11 and 12 she was already living it it's just as
she did have the words and when jesus explained it to her she found it absolutely unbelievable that
this is what could have been happening although she knew something very special was going on
and you he said you are also serene again and you made more of a practice of living in it now watch
this first of all jesus begins to work inside of us he begins to develop the kingdom in us as we
study what he has revealed to us as we enter into it as we try to pray it through and when he
eventually gets us to understand that we really are in this kingdom the effect is that we will
actually practice it more we will actually go into living in the kingdom of the divine will in a
much more intense way than we did before because now we actually understand what we're doing and i
will delight in expanding evermore the boundaries of my kingdom in you understood because it was
established up to what point the creature must take possession of the kingdom it's a very interesting
statement it is established that means the blessed trinity has already decided to what point any one
of us will experience the fullness of the divine will our destiny is already decided it's up to us
to cooperate and to grow and grow we can't guess and certainly we shouldn't make any guesses either
for ourselves or for anybody else since the boundaries of the kingdom of the divine will are endless
and the creature is incapable of embracing it all for the simple reason that she's limited
i just have a hunch and that's all it is now i have a hunch that he gets people to explore
different aspects of the kingdom none of us can enter into it all it's not actually possible and so
i've been encouraging people to follow the desire of their hearts because the lord will get individual
people to explore different aspects of the kingdom and between us all he'll get us to touch it all
we can't do it individually so louisa asks jesus another question in this final paragraph
you know how on earth are we going to persevere if adam failed she said how are we going to persevere
and he says you more help than adam had i think that's very interesting my love louisa said my fears
are not yet completely ceased how many times i am so frightened that that i fear i might act
like a second adam and jesus said to her my daughter don't fear you have much more help than adam did
you have the help of the translation says god illuminate i can't imagine however they got that
word from you you have the help of god incarnate it's what he's saying you have all of his works
you have all of his pains as your defense and as your support and as your courtage to accompany you
while he didn't have any of that so why do you fear rather be attentive to the sanctity that
befits the living in the celestial kingdom and on your happiness and fortune because by living
in the divine will one gaze of mine is enough for you it's enough for you to hear one of my words
to understand all of its goods and that's very very interesting we're not all going to master the
36 volumes but it's not actually necessary it's necessary to enter into the kingdom
and to cooperate with the lord and do as much as you can in the divine will in other words to live
it so for those outside of the kingdom of the divine will one can say that they understand only
that the kingdom of my will exists in other words they have theoretical knowledge but as for what's
inside of it what it takes to understand it they can barely grasp the alphabet of my will so if you
want a few references i can give them to you sam 78 verse 2 they never understood my ways
matthew 13 35 and mark 4 33 to 34 okay so we'll try another one even though we're a bit late so
if i do this i'll have to go over the time a little bit so july the 20th 1926 the word of Jesus is
work and his silence is rest it's very interesting so if i can give it to you very quickly that's
genesis chapter one the word went forth let there be light let all things come into being
and then they rest at the end of it so louisa said as i continued to feel all abandoned in the
supreme volition my beloved jesus made himself seen all silent in the act of looking at the whole
of creation at all of his works while looking at them he was as though enraptured profoundly
before the magnificence the sanctity the multiplicity and the greatness of his works and notice that
he was enraptured profoundly by the wonderful works that he has done and louisa said i together
with jesus felt a profound silence in me contemplating his works i think contemplating his works would
definitely lead to rounds of creation many things could be understood but everything would remain
in the depths of my intelligence with no words whatsoever how beautiful it was to be together
with jesus in profound silence then afterwards my dear god my sweet life told me my dearest daughter
you must know that my word is work in other words let there be light or be healed or lazarus
come forth just to give you a few examples while my silence is rest and my word is work not only
for me but also for you it is my usual way that after i have worked i want to rest in the midst of
my works so i want to give you the letter to the Hebrews chapter four verses three to four which
speaks about this rest that the lord wants us all to enter into so this is a Sabbath rest
so i want to rest in the midst of my works and this is the softest bed for me and since you have
listened to my word and have worked together with me with you you must also take rest so here you've
got their call to profound contemplation and adoration before the greatness of god
look my daughter he said how beautiful is the whole of creation it was the word of your jesus
that worked it with the fiat so go back to janice's chapter one and you have that fiat in every single
line it's absolutely fantastic so it's the fiat that's going forward and we have seen in the first
message tonight in the vision of jesus that the fiat was in his mouth in all the words that came
forth from his mouth well that's what you have in janice's chapter one so it was the word of your
jesus that worked it with one fiat but do you know what is the enchantment that enraptures me it is
your little i love you on each created thing so he doesn't want us to skip too much with this little
i love you of yours impressed on each of them i call that your signature they all speak to me
about your love and they speak to me about the newborn of my will i hear the harmonious echo of
the whole of creation that speaks to me about you there's an aspect of the realms that we may not
have underlined before and that is that you're not just putting your signature on everything
and claiming the kingdom of god jesus says that everything you put your i love you on actually praises
him for you which is fascinating oh how it enraptures me how happy i am to see that my fiat in creation
and the one taught to you hold hands intertwined together and fulfilling my will they give me rest
so we continue with the rounds in the next paragraph but i'm not content with resting alone
i want the one who gives me rest together with me so there's mark 314 when jesus start the work
of evangelizing israel st mark says he specifically chose 12 men to be with him he wanted them
together with him and in the divine will he wants us together with him in this work that he's doing
throughout the whole of humanity i want the one who gives me rest together with me that she
may take rest and we may enjoy together the fruits of our work isn't that fantastic
the divine will in him the divine will in us look do all creation and all the works of my redemption
not seem to you more beautiful with your i love you with your adoration and with your will transfused
in mine carrying out its life in the midst of the celestial fears he says as far as i'm concerned
it's more beautiful but i hope you appreciate that it's actually more beautiful there's no more
solitude he's talking about aloneness there this is a translation from italian and the
italian's have a huge problem with the word solitude i have thought with them for years about this
there's no more aloneness is what he's saying or that in dead silence that was there before
the celestial spheres and all my work so there was this dead silence and this terrible loneliness
he said unto all your i love you's life and the whole thing up like that's fantastic
and so we realized that we're really doing something that the lord is very pleased about and really
wants and there is the little daughter of my will keeping them company making her voice heard
because we're the speaking creation loving adoring and praying holding on to her rights
given to her by my will she possesses everything as i say if you put your signature on it it's yours
when there is someone who possesses there's no more of this loneliness nor is there the
silence of the grave anymore so this is why after having spoken to you at length i keep silent
it is the rest necessary for me and for you so that i may be able to resume my word again
now here is an explanation of the deprivations that has never been given before in other words
after communicating with louisa he goes back into silence and louisa never understood that silence
it's because he was working huge stuff with her in the deprivations as well but while i rest i
can't complete all my works my love rises within me and as it is reflected in me i delight and i
conceive within myself more images similar to me so he generates more children of the divine will
and my will places them outside of me as the triumph of my love and as the beloved generation
of my supreme fear your Romans 8 19 again so in my rest i generate children for my will all similar
to me and in my word i deliver them and give them development beauty and height that's greatness
and my word keeps forming them as worthy children of the supreme fear so you can see how absolutely
essential it is for us to be exposed to this material all the time because as the word is
delivered to us he is creating more children of the divine will and then he rests and so we have to
accompany him in this whole process because we have to have more and more and more and more people
coming into the divine will so in my word i deliver these children and give them development
beauty and greatness the word is height there and my word keeps forming them as worthy children of
the supreme fear i want to give you Philippians 1 6 and Ephesians 2 10 there were gods work of art
and created in christ jesus therefore my daughter each word of mine is a gift
can you imagine all that we have read tonight how much gift is in it for us
it's a gift that i give to you and if i call you to rest it is so that you may contemplate my gift
and delighting in it and loving it you may let more gifts rise within you similar to those that
i've given to you and as you release them they may form together the generation of the children
of the supreme fiat and so we become the mothers of the children of the divine will
how happy we will be jesus says and that's a nice place for us to stop tonight
so thank you for being with us and do let this word do its wonderful work